good afternoon um I'm really excited to
be here I know it's been a long day so I
appreciate you guys hanging out and and
I hope we can have a good time together
so let's start with this just to give me
context to know where I want to take
this talk how many people in this room
have no idea who I am or my schpeel
raise your hand that [ __ ] hurts Jesus
that's a bad way to start a talk I kind
of figured actually so well do is give
you a little bit of context of where I
come from so the things that I'm going
to talk about might make a lot of sense
I was born in a in Belarus in the former
Soviet Union and my family immigrated to
the United States in 1978 when I was
three years old we are we lived in a
small studio apartment in Queens New
York with nine family members one-eighth
of the size of this stage and it was
really quite difficult and it was
hardcore right it was super immigrant
you know you know it was my sister's
baby seat was a car seat found in the
garbage it was kind of raw my dad got a
job as a stock boy in in New Jersey and
was commuting from Queens to Jersey and
eventually worked really hard and became
the assistant manager then manager of
that store and eventually we moved to
Edison New Jersey Edison New Jersey is
where I started my entrepreneurial
career in Edison I basically put all my
friends to work so when I was six I had
eight lemonade stands in Edison New
Jersey a franchise you guys remember big
wheels that little like thing big wheels
I used to ride my big wheels in Edison
New Jersey and pick up my cash like I
was Tony Soprano it was pretty
interesting by the way on that note it's
amazing what you learn at such a young
age if you're entrepreneurial there was
a kid that you
to come just for the summers I didn't
know what divorce was or things of that
nature back then so I never understood
it his name was Eric Conrad he used to
come just for the summers and he was the
only friend of mine that actually made
signs and tried to sell stuff as well so
he always sold much more lemonade than
all my other friends however I would
always count how many cups I gave
everybody and he was actually stealing
he was actually taking a dollar to each
day but because his revenue was so much
higher I would let him go so it was
pretty fascinating you can learn a lot
when I was 11 I started my baseball card
business so I was doing baseball card
shows in the malls of New Jersey uh and
did quite well I was making two to three
thousand dollars a weekend selling
baseball cards and I was phenomenal I
don't know about you guys but when you
have thirty thousand dollars in cash
under your bed and you're 13 and you're
not selling weed you're doing a good job
so that was good and everything was
rockin it was going to be awesome I was
going to be the biggest baseball card
dealer of all time everything was great
and then I turned 14 and my dad ruined
my life see I was getting ready for one
of the biggest shows in New Jersey and
getting my cards together my dad walks
and he goes you're coming to the store I
go dad I think you're you're
misunderstanding I have a show today I'm
not quite sure how many of you have a
Soviet dad but I lost that argument so I
began to cry I basically cried the whole
40 minutes that we commuted because we
lived 40 minutes from the store down the
hall down Route 78 in Jersey the whole
way crying the whole way finally about
two minutes before we get there I
compose myself and I go dad how much are
you gonna pay me and he said two bucks
an hour and then I really started crying
and it was terrible for the next year
and a half every weekend of my life
every single Thanksgiving vacation every
single day of summer vacation every
weekend I was in my dad's basement of
the liquor store bagging ice for 10
hours a day for 2 bucks an hour how many
people in this room have seen the movie
The Goonies raise your hand I was sloth
that guy chained to the basement that
was me I hated it and it was terrible
then I turned 16 and was allowed
upstairs and my life changed I was on
the floor one day and every person came
in asking for Camus special select 1990
it was wine spectators wine of the Year
everybody and I was seeing all these
customers come in ask for the wine and
then leave and I was like this sucks
any good punk kid entrepreneur is not
going to let that happen so the next
person that comes in I'm gonna take a
back order now we didn't have a back
order system but I wasn't scared because
I was going to school on Monday anyway
so so the next person comes in he goes
you know I will take some Camus I'm like
great I'm like we're sold out but I can
take it back order using his name his
address I go how much would you like he
said well I'll take six cases and I was
a GU an alcoholic and I was like are you
having a party and he goes no no no I
collect wine and I was it literally you
know how you have these moments you
probably think about your own businesses
when like something changed or you
thought of it you can like literally
taste it I think I can literal I can you
zoom in like the goosebumps are here
like I can literally feel where I was in
my dad's old store in the Chardonnay
section when that moment happened
because I literally sat there at this
point I wanted to help my family I felt
like I could bring something to table I
was pretty ridiculous at 16 things you
know I knew what I could do I felt
confident so I remember sitting there
and saying silver oak Camus Opus one
Chateau Lafite Frank Thomas Ken Griffey
junior Wayne Gretzky saying [ __ ] I can
do this so literally literally literally
for the rest of my life
up until very recently I put every ounce
of my soul into becoming the greatest
wine expert I could and building a huge
wine business I literally sat in science
class that junior year reading The Wine
Spectator I didn't give a [ __ ] about
Saturn you know
I was so all in and that's what I
focused on now I did not grow up techy
the most teched-out that I was at 18
years old was that there's nobody in
this room that can beat me an NHL 94 for
Sega Genesis I literally didn't even
have a computer until I was somewhere
around 20 years old okay I was not
teched-out
I didn't grow up with it but what I'm
obsessed with what I'm about to talk to
you about for the rest of this evening
is culture shifts what people actually
do and how it affects it I'm about to
talk to you about social media but I'm
not a social media guy that's like oh
let's all be kumbaya and rock climb and
we're gonna drink tea and everybody's so
happy
I don't care why I like social media
ready headline ready here's why I like
social media because it sells [ __ ] so I
was hanging out with some nerd friends
in college and they're like check this
out there's this thing the Internet and
we could talk to chicks on this and so
that we heard the whole cool couch
nothing right and they went on and like
look we're talking to chicks and
literally within the first 20 seconds
I'm like I can sell stuff on this and so
I understood that this was going to be a
platform that mattered and 1996-1997 I
started plotting the a change for my
family business my dad's store was
called shoppers discount liquors I
wanted to build the brand so I launched
winelibrary.com in 1997 in 1998 I took
over daily operations and I grew that
business from a three to a sixty million
dollar business in a seven-year period
now I did that fairly traditionally I
did that through email and banner ads
which is traditional to me by the way
you know I did it through print and
radio and it was great I was very
fortunate because I sat next to my lead
developer in our office and he was very
tactile so name was Eric Kastner if
you're on twitter at Kastner ka st ner
hit him up tell him give him some love
anyway
he was showing me a different web there
was oath for it was a three oh four oh
five and I was like what is this stuff
what's this Friendster what's this
MySpace
we were on YouTube extremely early I'm
like this is changing see what I know is
this marketing for last 150 years has
been push every person in this room a
decade ago
had to do all push marketing to sit in
your seat whether it was radio or print
email services banner ads outdoor media
Direct Mail TV push for the last 150
years if you wanted to be good in
business and marketing such a component
of that you basically had to be a
quarterback you threw the ball and
whoever told their story best in the
right platform 100 years ago people
stood around a box the radio they're
like all right they liked it then they
watch TV but it was always push even
when the internet itself came it was
push banner ads and email services are
push we're living through the first time
ever when it's pull first time in the
first time in our history customers
actually have some assemblance of voice
and reaction and the culture ships were
living through our substantial culture
ships all of you got a long day you're
about to go eat dinner and drink some
wine and do some stuff and whatever I
really need you guys to do me a favor
please don't [ __ ] me lying is the
devil I need you to raise your hand high
when I ask this question
I have no interest in your [ __ ] head
nod or your half-ass hand I need your
full hand can you promise me that okay
how many people here three to five years
ago probably may be more likely to
whether you said it in public or to
yourself said the following thing I'm
not getting a facebook account for kids
why would I ever need one
don't [ __ ] lie raise your hands it's
a substantial number thank you very much
put him down how many of you right now
have a Facebook account
raise your hands guys
what just happened is the reason that I
am going to buy the New York Jets one
day my skill set and my belief is that I
got lucky
DNA wise to understand what people say
they're not going to do but are going to
do three years ago at South by Southwest
Dennis Crowley showed me Foursquare
raised like check this out everybody's
talking about it it's one of the first
hundred so users hanging out talking
about it somebody asked me Gary you're
gonna use Foursquare I said no I don't
use anything I just use it for business
but I think people will use it you guys
know that's so stupid why would I check
into Foursquare when I can just tweet
I'm somewhere this is not going to work
I said Billy said Billy let me ask you a
question
tonight when we go to a bar if you check
in and that bar then gives you a free
shot of Jack Daniels what are you gonna
do he said I'm gonna [ __ ] check it
and I said exactly we like to draw lines
in the sand 90% of this audience just
now which oh by the way and you might
even want to clap it up for yourselves
you guys are pretty badass so clap
yourselves up it'll be fun but you guys
are so [ __ ] smart and 90% of you said
I'm not going to do this and now you did
it and that to me is fascinating let's
go really wrong who wants to go wrong
how many people here 10 years ago said
they would never get a cell phone
because why would they want anybody to
contact them anytime they want don't lie
it's gonna hurt you're not gonna want to
raise your hand but raise it thank you
for the honest 40 of you how many of you
do not have a cell phone of those people
raise your hand zero this is happening
every day and marketing is being shifted
eyeballs are shifting the way we build
our businesses are shifting yet we
continue to do things like it's 2007 six
four two one I'm not mad at the way we
market our businesses in traditional
ways I'm really not but we have to
understand is that it's shifting let's
talk about outdoor media for one second
how many people here do outdoor media
just for context raise your hand you
guys are smart [ __ ] Bunch all right
that being said I do if you live in New
Jersey you might have driven the
Turnpike and seen a huge billboard of me
with a glass of wine I like outdoor
media makes you seem grand but when I
see companies spending money on outdoor
media I have a problem and here's what
it is do me a favor if you remember one
thing from this talk when your next home
the next time you're home whether that's
today or you fly back and you drive home
the next time you drive please look at
the five people at least five people
driving next to you while you're driving
just take a good hard look at five
people I'm going to tell you right now
three of them are texting Oprah's right
this [ __ ] is dangerous three of them so
let me just say for the record for all
the people at home running businesses
people are not looking at billboards and
outdoor media they're not even looking
at the [ __ ] road
how many people here can't wait to run
it and get their direct mail who's up
for that Direct Mail who's pumped I love
it when I'm like in these meetings that
people like we're still doing direct
mail we're a little bit more of a
conservative company Gary I get it do
you look at the REC mail [ __ ] no [ __ ]
how many people here have a TiVo or DVR
raise your hands how many people here
TiVo or DVR the majority of the shows
they watch on television how many people
here of those people in 2011 have
fast-forwarded every single commercial
for the year raise your hands hold them
up you know what [ __ ] it stand up please
do me a favor please I know you're tired
but this would mean so much to me please
stand up if you fast forward in every
single commercial in 2011 looking
kidding me and prices are up 18 percent
for commercials people aren't watching
them thank you guys so much that meant a
lot and exercise is good you know little
blood flow how many people watch
television with at least one screen in
front of them laptop phone or iPad raise
your hand how many people watch
television with two screens phone and
iPad how many people in this room watch
television with three phone iPad and
laptop raise your hands alright the 60
of you are sick of [ __ ]
yet yet every piece of creative on
television right now commercial does not
extend the story does not push the
content online
you don't watch a commercial where it
tells you to go to Facebook hit the
light button and see the rest and claim
your prize
Reebok hockey did a good job I don't
know if anybody saw this look it up
Sidney Crosby was playing his teammate
it was 2:5 they got the three and it
says you want to see how it finished go
to Facebook I click over and in 20
minutes 20 minutes
they picked up 62,000 pounds because
people watch and they're sitting right
there ready to be activated the business
world my friends in 2011 is acting like
2007 and that is where it is our
opportunity now what is the Thank You
economy why did I call thank you guys
thank you means you're welcome and what
can I do for you and how can I help you
this will probably be the most retweeted
quote of my entire talk I believe that
most people in this room and business
think about content how many of you in
here have heard content is king raise
your hand
everybody talks about content contents
so important your product itself content
commercials the way you advertise your
landing pages the UI the UX all that
stuff content is massively important and
your products not good you lose my wine
show that made me famous on the internet
I had to know what I was talking about
15 years that I spent learning wine
leading up to my first show is what made
it work however the real secret sauce
and to why I have 900 thousand followers
and things of that nature is the word
that is the single most important word
to every single company in this room
period the word the word for the next
decade context we are living in a
context war right now when I think about
content how good your product is how
creative your advertising is how well
you're converting your SEO or pay for
click to conversion and landing pages
all that [ __ ] when I think about that I
think about the quote that matters the
most right now which is when Eric
Schmidt six months ago said the amount
of content that we are producing as
human beings in this world right now
from the beginning of mankind like when
we fought dinosaurs and [ __ ] the
beginning until 2003
remember 2003 was like six seconds ago
from the beginning every radio every
piece of print every TV show every
billboard every song I'm not just
talking the US Russia China global every
piece of content that we as human beings
have created from the beginning of
mankind until 2003 is now being
replicated in volume every 48 hours no
wonder our kids Radd how is your content
going to break through in a world where
there's that much of it we all know that
everything is so fragmented the
watercooler about television I was
impossible there's 73 thousand shows and
video blogs and everything we're living
a more fragmented world so do you have
the audacity to think that your content
is going to break through and this is
where social comes in because we know
about global and we sure know that
companies like Google and other
companies are battling on a local level
right Google doesn't vizag at just for
their name if they don't think local is
really important over the next five
years however it is my firm belief that
the battle of marketing going forward
which means business is going to be
individual I believe that we are in the
dawn of one-on-one marketing and in that
one-on-one marketing world the stakes
are going to be very high for all of us
because something very ironic is
happening as we all go Jetsons the
action isn't being like The Flintstones
it is my firm belief that every single
person's grandparents are more prepared
to be successful in the next decade than
you guys because the way business was
built in the old days was built on small
town rules and what the internet is
doing it oh by the way let's talk about
the Internet this isn't about social
media I don't give a rat's ass about
Facebook or Twitter or Google+ these are
tools this is just the maturity of the
internet itself how many people here in
this room
not remember the world don't remember it
pre-internet just cannot do not remember
1993 raise your hand sir you do not
remember 1993 how old are you how much
36 it's only like 18 years why don't you
drink too much in college and you were
18
I didn't mean figuratively I mean the
far majority 99% of us remember the
world pre-internet this is all happened
very quickly all the stuff that's
relevant and that we talked about didn't
even exist a decade ago when I hear
people debate what's the ROI of social
media right like is it worth it like
what's the value like I'm not converting
it just makes me remember why I'm gonna
play over here it makes me remember why
so many businesses fail the problem is
most businesses are not playing the
marathon they're playing the Sprint
right they're not worried about lifetime
value and retention they're worried
about short-term goals social is not
going to excite anybody in this room for
what it's going to do to your bottom
line in a six month or twelve month
period it just can't happen see social
media marketing is like going beyond say
on your customers you've got to put a
[ __ ] ring on it meanwhile 99% of the
people here and I looked at some Twitter
and Facebook accounts and some of the
peeps in this room ninety percent of you
more but I'm trying to be nice are
treating social media like a one-night
stand most companies are failing and
social because everybody in social is
acting like a 19 year old dude they're
trying to close on the first transaction
it's going right the stakes are so
ridiculously high the first talk I ever
gave was about e-commerce in 1995 1996
guy came out with a PowerPoint and gave
so much data on why people would never
put their credit card into a computer
you would have left so convinced you
just couldn't even conceive of launching
a dot-com
there's no way there was a conservative
audience and then he was pretty gangster
actually respected his bravado he goes
and this kid's going to come out next
and tell you that you're going to buy
wine on the internet and everybody's
like ha ha ha ha
so I come out and my opening line is
first of all respect your gangster style
so thank you but number two the only
thing I wish is that this was being
recorded because in 10 to 15 years
mr. PowerPoint you're gonna be [ __ ]
wrong so that was my opening line by the
way he was and we know that what I am
shocked at right now is that people that
are building real businesses who've seen
this happen before every debate of the
ROI of social right now is the same
conversation we had about e-commerce
people don't want to bet on the culture
shift because it's not happening in the
next 20 minutes it's hard people don't
want to do that however I promise you
the companies in this room that don't
bet on it
don't go all-in because the big problem
is most people in this room are half
pregnant you're half in you kind of want
to be in but then you don't see the
quick results and you hedge you don't
understand what's really happening
because for the first time ever it's not
push for the first time ever marketing
isn't what I'm doing right now giving a
presentation and hoping it converts for
the first time ever it's a cocktail
party everybody's in play totally
different skill set of giving a good
presentation up here and then working
the room like a cocktail party totally
different I dominate both but some don't
let me give you an example that Thank
You economy we've created a thank you
department at winelibrary.com my
business it's not going to christen the
head of the thank you department which
oh by the way is not customer service
the Thank You Department is playing
offense customer service on social media
is playing defense so we're playing a
little offense customer comes in and
call Kristen go listen the books about
to come out I need some examples for
this crowd something that's relevant
something that's real intangible not me
just going up there and saying here do
it customer places an order from Chicago
and we find who he is on Twitter and we
follow him in the month of January and
here's what we saw Jay Cutler I love you
Superbowl runs through Chicago [ __ ]
Packers who suck and Rodgers are dead
yeah we won today next stop Super Bowl
today's the big game oh [ __ ] Jay
Cutler's hurt we're in trouble
crap we lost but I still love you Jay
Cutler okay we took that data so the
data I have in a normal 1995 world was
he likes Barolo and Brunello the
information I have today is what hits
him in the emotional center what he's
willing to put out to the world and what
paints a picture about who he is so I
called Kristen after she sent me this
day and I said Kristen here's what I
want you to do I want you to go to ebay
and I want you to buy a Jay Cutler
signed Jersey and send it to him with a
note saying thank you for your first
order with winelibrary.com
that was it and that was kind of the
talk I was giving for the first part of
the book to tell people about some of
the things were looking at that
consumers are putting out more data than
ever and we can really leverage that
data to give one-on-one marketing to win
their wallet because it's all about
lifetime value not about the spend you
get right now but over the last couple
weeks that story's changed on stage
because some good happen he finally
emailed back and he said hey you know
first of all I get Kristen thank you so
much
you know I'm a hedge fund guy in Chicago
I'm very
be busy I got the Jersey I love it it's
framed in my office I didn't have time
to write you back
amazing how did you know but I just want
you to know that I've spent hundreds of
thousands of dollars with Sam's in
Chicago which is a great store in
Chicago you should shop there great
store I've spent hundreds of thousands
of dollars there but they've never done
anything for me when I walk in the store
they don't even know who I am this
gesture means a lot to me and count
yourself as somebody that I want to do
business with the rest of my life now
that's fine and dandy that's big play
one on one how do you scale it right is
something that's going to be brought up
in the seats right now we do other
things we started doing something else
we call every single customer that
places in order now and thank them and
that's it Jersey is one of the few
states where you can actually record the
conversation of a phone call for pretty
interesting reasons I'm sure so I've
been able to actually listen to some of
these things here's how it goes hello
Susan this is Lily from winelibrary.com
I just wanted to call you and thank you
for your order hope you have a great day
uh-huh
that's it have a great day bye about 7%
of the people were calling right now or
calling back apologizing for being rude
because they thought there was going to
be another huge dropping on the phone
call that's where we got people got real
cynical we're always in sales mode see
it's super funny people are marketing
right now the way people plan weddings
it's really funny to me watching wedding
planning I bus done a lot of my wife's
friends about this I truly believe in my
heart that most people put way more time
and effort and oomph into planning their
running than putting energy into their
actual marriage and I truly believe that
that is the analogy of how people are
treating their business and marketing
tactics I firmly firmly believe that and
I really think about that every day I
believe that we're living through such
an unbelievable time let me paint you a
picture of 2017 how many of you are real
nerdy who knows what NFC technology is
raise your hand small mouth NFC it's a
chip and a phone near-field
communication here
it's gonna happen in 2016-17 ready I'm
gonna walk into Walgreens and I'm gonna
take out my phone because that's what we
all do all the [ __ ] time I'm just
gonna be looking at it while I'm looking
for some chips and [ __ ] and then I'm
going to see on my newsfeed whether it's
Facebook or Twitter or tumblr or
something else I really don't care
please don't care about that part and
I'm gonna see that Johnny says that
chocolate-covered pretzels from Weis are
delicious because oh by the way I don't
know if you know this we are social
creatures
we are sharing things on these platforms
that none of us would have ever picked
up the phone and called a friend about
nobody ten years ago was going to call
pick up the phone and call their friends
say Pinkberry watermelon is yummers
nobody does that but now all of you do
that all the time
we're extroverts even if we're
introverted the reason the fashion
industry is a good trillion dollar
industry is because inherently as
animals we want to express ourselves
it's how we roll
period that is the same dynamic and play
and social we want to do it I know when
you first saw Twitter you thought it was
a dumbest [ __ ] ever you said to yourself
who gives a [ __ ] if I'm eating a pizza
right I know what you thought the
problem is you didn't realize that this
social media game it isn't about talking
all of you need to wire your mouth shut
and start using your big [ __ ] ears
because that is the game in play so
what's going to happen is Johnny's going
to say chocolate covered pretzels or
yummers and I'm going to be like okay
and because wise potato chip company is
in play and has an incentive anytime
their brand is mentioned I'll see a
little icon I'll click and because
they're going to know that I'm in
Walgreens it's going to say buy wise
potato chips chocolate-covered pretzels
right now and get 50 cents off and you
know what I'm going to do I'm going to
buy those [ __ ] pretzels and you know
what that is ROI and when you start
looking at status updates or pushes in a
social environment that is not done by
your companies but it's done by word of
mouth of the ecosystem and you can see
that this one comment led to seventy
four thousand dollars in transactions
whether you have a store or a website or
whatever it is
that's when people are going to start
paying attention because what every
person knows in this room how many
people here have gotten some form of
business because of word-of-mouth raise
your hand all of you period
word-of-mouth is the currency and now we
have infrastructure for word-of-mouth to
be on steroids word of mouth is hanging
out with Barry [ __ ] Bonds
it carries dramatically further than it
ever did before when I used to do my
surprise and delights back in the day it
didn't carry the weight it does today
when I had a lady call me from Bergen
County complaining because FedEx threw
her package in the bushes and she
couldn't get it because she was 647
years old and on three days before
Christmas I took a case of behringer
white sin and threw it in my car and
drove it up there and gave it to her
during peak hours I wasn't gonna get
pressed for that 60 minutes wasn't
following me but today our actions and
our engagements are being spread they
just are and every day our consumer base
no matter who you're reaching is getting
more and more into that ecosystem and
sure you see things like what Facebook
did this week to push those envelopes
and they might go too far and it comes
back and it flows but the cats out of
the bag because the fundamental fact of
the matter is is even though it's going
through your mind right now nobody gives
a [ __ ] about privacy I know some of you
think I'm a [ __ ] right now but I'm
telling you I'm not I'll tell you why
because the cause of privacy the pain
point of privacy is money right and
health see the news and traditional
media have told us that were bad the
most underrated brand in the world my
friends is us brand human being is the
number one underrated thing the problem
is we always watch the news and they
tell us how bad we are we killed this
kid we raped that kid we stole this car
you only hear the bad but if you look at
the data in the world we're living in
now where people know where you are all
the time it is stunning
how little bad stuff is going on it's
shocking by data but we don't want to
talk about that and so we focus on
things that nobody cares about remember
Foursquare and everybody said well now
people are going to rob your home when
you check into places well when you left
a status update on Facebook saying
you're on
they could have done it - nothing
changed it's just the same argument
being recycled all the time we're living
in one business all of us one we are in
the eyeballs and ears business no matter
what you do and how you roll b2b or b2c
you are in the eyeballs and ears
business we are trying to convert we are
living through a massive culture shift
of where those eyes and ears go we just
do and what I'm fascinated by is what
happens when you start creating context
how many people here knew of me before I
gave this talk and looking at the crowd
a lot of you I know as well
I know Rizzo right over here right I
have different context towards him
I feel differently when I was out here
talking I was like [ __ ] his beards
getting heavier like you know I've
context I have an emotional relationship
a bunch of you now we're going to come
to the table at the book signing and
we're gonna create more context I am
fascinated by what you're willing to do
for your mother that you're not willing
to do for your brother and that for your
brother what you're not willing to do
for your best friend and for your best
friend when you're not willing to do for
an acquaintance and for your Queens when
you're not willing to do for a co-worker
and for your coworker what you're not
willing to do to a kind of stranger and
for that kind of stranger what you're
willing to do that you're not willing to
do to a perfect stranger like balki
bartokomous my ram anyway that is the
game I believe that companies have the
opportunity to take themselves from a
nonhuman element to a human element I
believe and this is about to get real
weird so stick with me for a half a sec
I believe that we're living through the
beginning of the humanization of logos
that we are going to have relationship
with logos I equate it very similar to
what's happened with a pet dog if you
look at the data of the pet dog in the
1950s spot spent most of his time
outside now spots inside but I think as
many of you know spots pretty aggressive
he actually doesn't only live inside he
lives in your bedroom and I don't know
about this but you may know spot
actually wears better clothes than you
do
anywhere's better clothes and he eats
better than you do because he eats
gourmet every single night you don't
leave your kids into your bedroom and
spot sleeps on your bed that is what has
happened with the data we have humanized
spot once we're done humanizing our
circle we humanize our pet and if you
start looking lipton brisk ice-t is one
of our clients during the NBA Draft this
year we had one of the highest
engagements around the NBA Draft with
Lipton brisk because people were asking
hey @ Lipton risk what do you think
about that pick in the second round
truely treating our logo like their boy
truly humanizing why because when we
engage on Facebook and Twitter and these
platforms we're not just using it as a
press release so many of the companies
in here when I was doing my little
search are using their Facebook pages as
another newsletter how many people here
have done email marketing in their
career raise your hand a lot how many of
you have done it for more than seven
years raise your hand just curious okay
so the 30 of you will know exactly what
I'm talking about open rates on email
are nowhere close to what they used to
be 10 years ago do you guys remember how
much this country loved email 15 years
ago they made a movie called you've got
mail we loved it
you were so it was like Christmas back
in the day when you heard you got mail
you're like yes you punked how many
people here love email now if you look
at email open rates over the last since
mid 2000 last two years they're down 20%
globally down the whole Groupon and
LivingSocial phenomenon that deal of a
gilt groupe Kevin was speaking here
today about operations that whole crew
those guys mastered the email game and
conversion but remember how you felt two
years ago when you first found out about
one of these sites you couldn't wait
couldn't wait to buy $40 worth of sushi
for 20 bucks you were so pumped to get a
bikini wax for Half Price you were
pumped now the email open rates are so
down you don't give a [ __ ] if Groupons
offering you a million dollar home for
300 bucks you're deleting that [ __ ] of
spam
because here's the big point everything
I believe about the new social web
everything I wrote about in my book will
be ruined in five years seriously
everything I truly believe in from a
marketing standpoint will be ruined five
years from today because there's a funny
little secret marketers ruin everything
everything I believe that's coming from
the right place is going to become a
tactic and people going to be doing
these things over and over it's going to
be the free shipping rule free shipping
winelibrary.com 1998 first time we ever
did it we sold so much wine that weekend
I was in a store till 5:00 in the
morning and then coming back in at 7:00
for three days in a row just to catch up
with all the orders we sold so much that
wine that weekend it's like people
thought their Cure was inside of all
those wine bottles one guy places an
order and this notes says thank you so
much for doing this perfect for me my
daughter I'm going to buy this for my
daughter's wedding me living in the
Thank You economy back then and not
knowing what it was decide to call him
and thank him Jim thank you so much
where is the wedding I'd like to send a
nice bottle of champagne to celebrate
the wedding he goes oh no no no Gary
my daughter is 12 years old
I said what because my daughter is 12
years old he goes but this is such a
sick deal I'm gonna put this wine in the
basement and we'll save it for her
wedding now every single person in this
room 13 years later doesn't buy anything
online unless it has free shipping we're
all primed out and everything else this
is going to become a tactic we have a 36
to 60 month window to create context we
know what happens when we touch our
consumers our Twitter customers at Wine
Library calm are outperforming our non
Twitter engaged customers by 60% because
we created context we answered a wine
question they feel more emotional about
us and they're buying from us that is
how it used to be in the small town
rules in the 1930s and 40s when you went
to your butcher store the second you
open that door that man was cutting your
roast beef because he knew things about
you you lived in a small town room we
literally left our laundry outside we
left our front doors open we knew a lot
about each other we are now replicating
that how many people here have connected
with somebody on Facebook that they have
not talked to prior to that in over 10
years raise your hands almost everybody
how about 20 years crazy half 30 40
you don't even look 40 looking good my
man some good show what do you find your
friend will like second hello when you
were three look good you look at two 436
by the way but your memories [ __ ] your
social graph is bigger than it ever was
Dunbar's number is [ __ ] it's going to
be bigger and what's going to happen is
those people in your lives who are much
more emotionally pointed to your heart
than a banner ad or an email newsletter
or a piece of mail or a commercial that
you never watched by the way or outdoor
media is going to convert better
word-of-mouth is going to scale your
scrap is bigger people are going to
recommend products we're not going to
hide anywhere no more worrying about
Yelp because the next Yelp is the one
that doesn't let you be anybody but your
true self and we're going to go to real
identity when we go then then your
social equity is going to drive your
business then doing the right thing is
going to really matter we live in a
crazy world
I'm a micro Micro Micro Micro Micro
celebrity on the internet and I went to
my brother-in-law's bachelor party in
Vegas last October this is my wife's
brother if there was an ever a time you
can go to the strip club in Vegas this
was it and when the boys were like let's
go I'm like [ __ ] it I don't want a
Twitpic of me in there we are living in
a world where there's no hiding most of
my corporate clients two three years ago
I started a company called vaynermedia
doing community management strategy for
big brands PepsiCo and Campbell's and
Green Mountain coffee and GE big boy
brands not entrepreneurial stuff big boy
brands big girl brands and they always
tell me Gary but what about when we have
a problem you know what happens when we
you know something happens and they all
come in the question always is well were
you wrong they're like yeah but I'm like
no no if you're feeding children [ __ ]
that's going to make them sick you
deserve to lose that's what's going to
happen the way we all do business is
going to change so fundamentally by
these culture shifts I'm going to watch
a New York Jets game in ten years on my
new Apple television not that dorky
thing that everybody has to hook
up like the television and when Mark
Sanchez throws a touchdown pass my
remote control which is going to look
something like an iPad it's going to say
do you want to buy a Mark Sanchez Jersey
and at the height of my excitement I'm
going to say yes and the height of your
excitement when you're watching
something that looks like Gossip Girl in
Sex in the City and you're gonna be like
oh my god Pamela's shoes are so [ __ ]
phenomenal you're gonna buy two pairs
the culture we live in is going to shift
constantly guys I don't know if you're
paying attention
SEO is dying in front of our eyes SEO is
changing the way we search I'm Google's
in such an interesting place I mean I
don't know about you guys how many
people here have recently had something
come up and where as in three or four
years ago you would have won to Google
and search you went to Twitter and
searched raise your hand just curious
small amount which is interesting to me
based on this demo I beg you to try to
remember to do this the next time
something catches your eye to go to
Twitter search instead of Google search
and see what your experience is like see
how it's different because real-time
search brings enormous context and value
and how that ecosystem works is
fascinating to me including excuse me
including buying ads in real time as a
current event is happening what happens
during a hurricane when you've got extra
you know tape or whatever the hell you
need for a hurricane you know or during
a huge snowstorm when a small company
puts out that they have shovels when
everybody's searching to check the news
on it and you're the first ad there this
is being replicated everything that
helped me build my business with Google
is now being replicated in social search
and more importantly the algorithm of
the news feed today that goes in my face
from social is so much more important to
me than the SEO of Google and I know
because I look at this stuff when you go
to Google you have intent to buy more
often than social but what happens when
that becomes your ecosystem see what's
fascinating to me is this this room is
very smart very smart I'm super pumped
to be here it by the way I love this
whole conference and I love the thought
of five hundred and five thousand and I
get blown away when I was doing the
homework on the way here if this is
de la créme because your entrepreneurial
this is you know to get in here you've
got to be growing so you have a big base
and looking at how young this space is
I'm shocked from oh six to be here I
thought that everybody would know but
I'm starting to learn it takes time and
that's where the opportunity is it blows
my mind that I can sit in a conference
like this and say it's not too late it
blows my mind that how many people here
for their business whether it's you or
somebody in your business go to
twitter.com slash search and search your
brand or things around your brand every
single day raise your hand that's like
four percent of this room that means
there's a huge opportunity creme de la
creme four percent which means nobody
else is really doing it right now
on your BlackBerry or phone you can
search your brand your handle on
twitter.com slash search and see what
people are saying about you it is 2012
almost my friends I have no idea how you
can justify leaving any engagement
behind on the social web in a 2011 2012
world none of you would be going out to
pizza in your local town sitting next to
a couple hearing talking about your
business and you would have stayed shut
none of you you would have all get
conned up and said thank you or how can
I help you or couldn't help but overhear
but that's my company thank you so much
none of you yet all of you are leaving
that in a scalable way on a daily basis
the reason I was able to grow my
businesses was not because I was putting
out good content it's because every day
after producing 30 minutes of wine
television I spent 15 hours a day
answering every single person's email
and every single person's Twitter at
reply and created context and
relationship with that end user these
are the [ __ ] people that buy our [ __ ]
and you're worried about all your
internal [ __ ] and you should because I'm
obsessed with operations but I know
people have been talking about that all
day these are the people that put the
cash in your wallet and we are leaving
these engagements on the table it blows
my mind do you know how fun it is to
answer what white wine goes with fish
sixty eight thousand times a year it
sucks [ __ ] but I did it
by the way it's not Pinot Grigio get
over that [ __ ] content is going to
continue to grow the ability to build a
business in an online world is so low if
you think about the entrepreneurs before
us
they were so unlucky it costs so much
more capital and time to build a
business
the piping of the Internet and the
ecosystem we live in has allowed
companies to come out of nowhere very
very quickly what that means for all of
you is that it's a race it's a branding
race but most of all it's a context race
to me I start getting fascinated when
companies start worrying about acquiring
and start worrying about holding on to
when companies stop worrying about
hunting and start worrying about farming
you know ideally right they won right
one of our first clients when we first
started with them a lot of push look at
our shoes look at this
we built a community talking about
fashion and then conversion went up
Kevin Ryan gilt groupe those guys in
Groupon and LivingSocial local company
here LivingSocial they understood how to
map acquiring customers it's a science
they figured it out
they haven't cost they retargeted they
put little cookies on you you saw their
ad everywhere and they figured out the
cost the problem is when you look at a
lot of businesses like those and others
they're real challenge is retention
retention is the game lifetime value is
the game and there's only one way to do
it
humans it's crazy I'm building companies
that have a crapload of humans it's
crazy the human being is the value like
I said as we go new wave
the human being is where it's at you
can't outsource it
you can't automate real feelings I'll
leave you with this and I want to do a
couple questions I was in the room with
a very conservative CMO and she was
really drilling me she was like but
what's the ROI of social media and I'm
giving her my best stuff for example if
you want some best stuff go look at what
your engagement rate is on your Facebook
page you have a certain amount of fans
and then you have a post though
the number is a point oh one is a point
oh two it doesn't matter how many fans
and Twitter followers you have it's how
many of them are going to buy something
and give a [ __ ]
so she's drilling mean I'm giving her
some really good metrics at least for a
2011 world and she's pushing and I know
why she works in a conservative company
and the more conservative she comes
across the more likely she'll be the CEO
I get it I'm fine
but she's pushing and pushing and
finally I look at her and I go she's
like but Gary what's the ROI and I'm
like today she's like but what's the
real ROI of social media and I'm doing
my normal thing like can you give me the
ROI of television and print because I
love that you spend a shitload of money
on Vogue and you're buying the
subscription but can you guarantee me
that somebody's looking at the ad on
page 139 cuz you can't and I'm giving
her everything I've got and she's still
punching me directly in the throat so I
had to pull it out she goes what's the
ROI of social media what's the ROI of
social media so I look at her and go
what's the ROI of your mother she said
excuse me I said oh
I said I have no interest in making a
mother joke and I'm not making fun of
you but let me explain one thing to the
ROI of my mother is everything the
reason I'm going to buy a multi-billion
dollar sports franchise is because of my
mother my mother
the way she parented me which oh by the
way is perfectly is the reason I have
the ability the confidence and absolute
wherewithal to execute the businesses
that I'm building however my friends at
Inc 500 I cannot come to you with slides
and put him on those screens and say
over here click in sixth grade when I
got a mullet you know and my mom said I
was gorgeous and beautiful and I could
do anything
well that was building self esteem and
so what I did with that it on the next
slide is you'll see here I sold a couple
more cases of wine in 1994 because of
that self-esteem which led to this and
now I can't show you I can't show you in
data the ROI of my mother but I promise
you it's all of it the whole kit and
caboodle socials going to prove it
because social has way better metrics
than traditional some [ __ ] stood at
the top of a building with a clicker and
counted how many cars drove by a
billboard and that's the metrics we're
using do you know that people do little
[ __ ] scantron like cards to tell
Nielsen's what shows they watched are
you [ __ ] kidding me however thank you
for that one clap that meant a lot
however however we keep poking holes in
social you know why I know the size of
your company similar to where I'm used
to you're busy you're doing a lot of
stuff and you need to grow I get it but
please bought it yourself figure out
what you're doing when people always
talk to me and say but how do you scale
this I say you take all the money you're
spending on dumb [ __ ] and you put it
into humans thank you
I mean us standing up you're my only
step [ __ ] thank you back so I think
thank you so much
I think I'm 2 minutes for Q&A oh [ __ ]
this is heavy
ok who's got a question the shellman
over here the showman over here ha ha ha
ha 36 I can't remember [ __ ] Hey help
what's your name of me I'm John and nice
to meet you hi nice to meet you too you
you're awesome
ok so one of my goals was to figure out
the social media deal so I appreciate
you what your words are I own a
newspaper company ok so market biggest
concern is how do you monetize the
content contents good but how do you you
know what is a media company you know
how do we look at that guys listen media
is a commodity now it's it's it's just
truth listen some dude bought 1200
horses the day before Henry Ford created
the car he [ __ ] lost right I mean
that's just the way it is business
doesn't give a [ __ ] innovation doesn't
give a [ __ ] about you me or anybody what
you need to do is take that brand equity
and while you've got some eyeballs there
and start understanding how to convert
them into something else
I mean it's just the truth holding on to
what emotionally feels good is a really
good way to go out of business you know
I mean that's just the way that's the
truth of the matter it's gonna be very
hard for you or any of the smart people
here to sit around in a brainstorming
session and say okay who's reading
newspapers in 12 years and you're a
young dude so I would take that brand
equity and I would start siphoning as
quick like like like the way you siphon
gas as fast as you [ __ ] can to get
them to go to some other platform
monetizing content is extremely
difficult however look at a site called
refinery29
it's a fashion sites a competitor of
ideal ease they've done a really good
job with content and commerce you've got
to really rethink this man I mean
there's just there's nothing cute about
it I mean you know we know that the
music industry got disrupted right
clearly your industry did but I promise
you the thing that this room is under
estimating is communication has been
disrupted how many of you have children
nieces or nephews that are between 12
and 18 years old raise your hand so you
guys know I love this debate three years
ago when I heard like parents my friends
are in their 30s and 40s saying I'm
never
texts with my child they want me to tax
only phone call how many of you remember
having that thought yeah how many of you
now are texting only with your children
exactly so the fact that matter is is
that communications being disrupted
content for commodity it's a commodity
anybody can do it
everybody's gonna cry about the
journalistic quality great if you're so
[ __ ] good when if it's so good if it's
such good journalism then win and so
it's top man every 48 hours I mean
that's just the truth of the matter and
the way distribution is done it's just
been disrupted and so what I would tell
you to do is take the last equity or all
the equity that you have there really
think about what you're doing with it
yeah question yeah right here
what's your name with me I'm Jacob Dalek
how are you good how are you doing
good um were you about to introduce to
us your team this is my partner Aaron
also brother how are we own a company
called cheap ink and we sell ink
cartridges and toner okay and we are
launching our e-commerce website and we
know that it's a field that is pretty
saturated and we are very focused on
doing a lot of things to differentiate
ourselves in it we've been in it for
nine years so we're familiar with it
yeah you know what my question is we are
we're trying to do things on Facebook
and use social media to market ourselves
button cartridges and tone are not the
sexiest of products and it waters a
boner about it it's pretty excited huh
English the [ __ ] man a me too I'm
definitely like you know change you know
turn that frown upside down and you're
like it could no no it's not a frown I
mean I have some ideas about it but no
but I get it I'm making a joke my
question my question to you my question
to you is how do I make it interesting
or do I have to I'll tell you that media
literally if we ran into a coffee shop
and I was giving you 20 minutes of ice
I've got the piece right now map
everybody who you know is the buyer of
in office right cuz I let me ask let me
ask a better question how much of your
business is b2b like how much is it the
buyer or the office manager it's not the
individual right it's a mysterious it is
a mixture of individuals and also small
medium
the mixture what's the mixture yeah it's
more b2b how much
6040 problem okay so you know one thing
I would definitely use is a combination
of LinkedIn and Twitter and Facebook map
your entire consumer base right so
everybody how many people do you have in
your customer database right now I mean
right now we're relaunching a product
right now our product right now it's got
customers right yeah we have about 50 to
100
oh so it's really it's like a small
group of people yes I mean we so first
and foremost how much Thank You economy
stuff are you doing with those 50 200
people because honestly I'd be at their
house shoveling their [ __ ] driveways
during snow sleet you know what I mean
so first things first I Papa that was
just little fun but first things first I
highly recommend that you go really deep
emotionally with that small of a
customer base I'm dying to know when the
last time you talked to them casually in
a non business way has happened with
those 50 to 100k brothers stand up how
many times we talk with our customers on
instant message all that pretty
regularly actually I would highly
recommend trying to shift into some sort
of emotional center right so like a good
example is one of the people we worked
with that Quaker client he mentioned
something really subtly that he played
high school football for one day because
he went from soccer to football and he
was trying to blitz as a linebacker and
this offensive tackle threw him into
like you know the next state and he
mentioned the player and it wasn't
actually a player that played for the
NFL when we got back I ordered that
players Jersey and sent it to him
there's ways to have real relationships
with people when you have a small of a
customer base as you guys have those 50
200 people literally need to become your
best friends yeah and we're trying to
grow that significantly the core sort of
I guess what when you when you have 600
of them those [ __ ] need to be your
best friends - yep you know what I mean
absolutely so I I think that's one thing
to understand and by the way you should
map who they are socially back to my Jay
Cutler story you should email them and
ask them who they are in Facebook and
Twitter and friends or them and watch
what they're talking about you'd be
stunned in Thank You economy my book
there's one tweet where somebody
complains about a phone service somebody
jumps in helps them and lands a $250,000
gig
based on one tweet you know what I call
that ROI so yeah I was thinking that we
could even add it in when we're asking
them to sign up and things like that so
that they know that we're actively
engaging with them beyond it's good but
push that human element you got you're
sitting in such a great spot as a
business to be that small of a customer
base you could really push the envelope
you know going through a survey is not
human you calling and being like how's
your day going like what other needs can
we have like notice that you have your
power went out on Twitter I'm coming
over with my generator that's how you
keep somebody for the rest of their
lives
sure and that data is being put out now
that it wasn't ten years ago and you
know why people aren't gonna do it cuz
it's [ __ ] hard and people are dicks
but if you're a good guy you can win
well and that's what we're trying to do
we want to be as close to our customers
as possible to make them happy so that
you do I use one more thing yeah we're
from Chicago easy on Jacobs yeah alright
one more and then I think I got to do
the book signing yes sir what's your
name my name is Jeff thanks for thanks
for taking my question sure Mia was good
stuff right liked what she had to say
Thanks um I'm talking about when you're
you're you're kind of talking about what
would you do for your mother and then
for your brother yeah for a complete
stranger yeah I started a company called
red monkey foods we do gourmet
seasonings and spices so since I am a
complete stranger would you mind
tweeting about it to your nine hundred
thousand friends
good hustle I'm obsessed with hustle
right but see what I find interesting is
even though I just gave it an really
passionate talk you went for the 19 year
old dude move right you tried to close
on our first transaction and so that
gives you a big [ __ ] no but but I do
love your swag and your hustle and
that's why you're sitting in the room
you go and hedge that you know we're all
the guys I told you my first business
was lemonade stands because I really
didn't want to tell you what it really
was my first business was really four
and a half I used to go to people's
yards rip their flowers out of their
yard ring their doorbell and sell it
back to them so unlike you I'm gangster
right
I'm sales I'm not up here mother Teresa
love you're 50 people I only remember
you forgot because it was an hour ago I
only do this because it's how business
is going to be done I'm only interested
in this stuff because it converts and
it's going to be the only thing against
the amount of noise that's going to be
going on in the world so what would have
been more interesting is when I talked
about you know the stake I was having
for you to like send and say hey I saw
you in 500 and I'm sending you a little
you know spice that would go really
great with that and then I would say ah
good thank you economy tactic let me
retweet it but now you [ __ ] blew it
but there's a lot of other but there's a
lot of other pretty girls out there so
the next time you go into the social
media bar don't be a douchebag roll deep
thank you
you